はじめ）たなっち
たなっち）はい
はじめ）酒飲むつったらやることはなんだ
たなっち）せっ…(ニヤ
はじめ）セ(ピーーー)ではなーーーーい
はじめ）斉藤さんでございます
たなっち）はい
はじめ）なんか昔もやったことあるんですけど
はじめ）結構評判良かったんで
たなっち）はい
はじめ）まぁ年1とも言わず
はじめ）なんかこう
はじめ）まぁゆっくりしたいとこあるんでちょっと
はじめ）お酒でも飲みながら斉藤さんでね
はじめ）いろんな人とお話しして楽しもうと思います
たなっち）去年の夏ぶりとかですか？
はじめ）去年の夏ぶり
たなっち）すげーじゃもうほとんど1年なんですね
はじめ）そう
はじめ）あざーす
たなっち）かんぱーい
はじめ）ではいくぜー
男の子）もしもーし
はじめ）もしもーし
男の子）もしもし？
はじめ）あ、こんばんは
はじめ）えっ………
はじめ）おじさんだよ
男の子）ん？
はじめ）おじ、おじさんですよ全然
男の子）あっ、おじさん？
はじめ）うん、何歳？
ﾄｩﾙﾙﾙﾝ
たなっち）やばっ12才
はじめ）12才⁉︎
はじめ）何やってんのこの時間に
たなっち）あれですね多分声変わりしてない男の子だった
はじめ）もしもーし
ﾄｩﾙﾙﾙﾝ
たなっち）うわ
はじめ）ふわぁ
はじめ）たなっち女の人の声出せる？
たなっち:女の人の声で）無理ぃ
はじめ）ｗｗｗ厳しいｗ
たなっち:女声）無理ぃ
はじめ）でもそれで1回いってみよう
たなっち:女声）もしもーし
男性）もしもし
男性）こんばんは
たなっち:女声）こんばんは
男性）何歳ですか？
たなっち:女声）22です
たなっち:女声）バレました？
男性）いや、バレバレですね〜
たなっち:普通に戻って）やっぱむずいっすよね女の人の声なんて
男性）いやーむずいですねーほんと
はじめ）1回真似してみてくだい女の人の声
男性）自分野球部なんでできませんよほんと
はじめ）いや、大丈夫っす　野球部なりの女の子の声を
男性）じゃ1発かましますよ
はじめ）お願いします
男性:女声）もしもーし
ﾄｩﾙﾙﾙﾝ
たなっち）あぁ…
はじめ）もしもーし
男性）あ、もしもーし
はじめ）待って待って
はじめ）野球部？
男性）え？
はじめ）野球部ですか？
男性）なんで野球部なの
はじめ）え？野球部じゃないですか？
男性）はじめんなの？
はじめ）え⁉︎よくわかったね
男性）え？
はじめ）よくわかりましたね
男性）いや、はじめんだったらマジびっくりするけどね
はじめ）いや、マジはじめんだよ
男性）え⁉︎
はじめ）マジはじめん
男性）マジで声は似てるけど
はじめ）うん
男性）マジではじめん？
はじめ）マジでｗはじめん
男性）証拠は？なんか証拠的な
男性）え、マジではじめんなの？
はじめ）うん
男性）うそやー
はじめ）ほんとほんと
はじめ）こんばんは
男性）ほんとに？
はじめ）うん
はじめ）はっははｗｗ証拠ｗ
男性）証拠は？
はじめ）証拠…じゃ顔写してあげる
男性）マジか
はじめ）うん
男性）うわーマジはじめんだ
はじめ）こんばんは
男性）すげーえ、じゃぁ
男性）写真ｔ　　ﾄｩﾙﾙﾙﾝ
たなっち）ふっｗｗｗ　鬼や
たなっち）いつも動画見てて思ってたけど鬼や斉藤さんの時
はじめ）はははははｗｗ
お兄さん）もしも〜し
はじめ）あっこんばんは何されてるんですか？今
はじめ）どこ、え、誰？え、何歳ですか？
お兄さん）26で〜す
はじめ）うぇめっちゃ歳近いっす　僕25です
お兄さん）あっそうなんすか
はじめ）そうなんです
お兄さん）何してんですか今
はじめ）今……
はじめ）斉藤さん…お酒飲みながら斉藤さんしてます
お兄さん）ふ〜〜〜ん
はじめ）お仕事、お仕事終わりですか？
お兄さん）は〜い
はじめ）わぁーお疲れ様です
お兄さん）そっちは？
はじめ）こっちは今、今日も疲れたねってお酒飲みながら斉藤さんしてました
お兄さん）ふ〜〜〜ん
お兄さん）どこの人ですか？
ﾄｩﾙﾙﾙﾝ
はじめ）もしもーし
男性）ハロー
はじめ）ハロー
はじめ）ハロー　ハワィユー
はじめ）オーゥ
男性）アイムファイン
はじめ）アーユーファイン？
男性）センキュー
はじめ）オーゥ ミー
はじめ）センキューセンキュー
はじめ）ン〜ワッチュユアネーム？
男性）テンキュテンキュー
男性）ゥワァ〜〜〜ィ
はじめ）ワァ〜〜〜〜ォ
はじめ）ワッチュアネーム？
男性）ｗｗ
男性）ん〜〜〜〜？才
はじめ）お　え？
ﾄｩﾙﾙﾙﾝ
はじめ）おぉ
はじめ）英語　外国人ノリでいった方がいいかもしれない
たなっち）あー確かに
はじめ）ﾊﾟｯﾊﾟｯﾊﾟｯﾊﾟｯ
男性）もしもーし
はじめ）ハロー　オゥ　ハロー
男性）おっ、ハロー
はじめ）ハロー
男性）ハロー　ナイストゥミーチュー
はじめ）ナイスミチュー
男性）マシーマシー
はじめ）マーシー？
男性）マーシー
はじめ）マーシー
男性）オッケーユアネイム？
はじめ）マイネイムイズ
男性）おっ
男性）ん？ｗｗなんてｗわっ
男性）ワンモアプリーズワンモアプリーズ
ﾄｩﾙﾙﾙﾝ
はじめ）ハロー
男性）ハロー　ハハッ
はじめ）ホホゥ　ミッキーマウス？
男性）ふふｗｗ
はじめ）ン〜ワッ　ワッチュアネーム
男性）ミッキー
男性）マイネイムイズ　ミッキーマウス
はじめ）ミッキー？？
男性）ミッキー
男性）ミッキーｗｗ
はじめ）ワハハーゥ　ハハハ
はじめ）あ？
男性）あ？
はじめ）あぁ？
男性）あぁ？
はじめ）あぁあ？
男性）あぁあ？
男性）ふははははははははｗｗｗｗ
はじめ）アデュー
男性）アデュー
ﾄｩﾙﾙﾙﾝ
はじめ）もしもーし
女の子）もしもーし
はじめ）こんばんは何歳ですか？
はじめ）16歳⁉︎すげー若っ
女の子）何歳ですか？
はじめ）何歳だと思いますか？
はじめ）うあああああ惜しい25でした
たなっち）ｗｗｗ
はじめ）ｗｗｗ　うふふ
はじめ）もう16歳からしたら25歳とかおじさんでしょ
はじめ）ほんとに⁉︎ おーー
たなっち）へー
はじめ）ちなみに16歳今高校生ってこと？
はじめ）1週間学校お疲れ様、学校楽しい？
ﾄｩﾙﾙﾙﾝ
はじめ･たなっち）うおおおおああああああ
はじめ）もしもーし
女の子）もしもし
はじめ）えっえっ可愛い可愛い
はじめ）可愛い
たなっち）いやいやわかんないすよ
はじめ）わかんないすか
はじめ）こん、こんばんは
女の子）こんばんは
はじめ）うわぁ声可愛いですね
女の子）え？あ、ふふ
女の子）あ、えへへ
はじめ）わああああ
たなっち）え、何歳ですか？
はじめ）うわあああああああ
はじめ）若いなぁってことは高校生ってこと？
女の子）うふふ　うふふ
はじめ）うわ　"$%*  笑った声が可愛いぃぃぃ
女の子）いやぁ
はじめ）はぁはぁはぁはぁはぁ
たなっち）あーねぇちょっとｗ
はじめ）あぁｗそうだ
はじめ）じゃ土曜日日曜日　休日を楽しんでくださいね
女の子）ありがとうございます
はじめ）はい、以上はじめしゃちょーでした
はじめ）お疲れ様でした
女の子）はい
ﾄｩﾙﾙﾙﾝ
はじめ）もしもーし
女の子？）もしもーし
はじめ）うわっとこんばんは
女の子？）こんばんは
はじめ）何されてたんですか？
男性）ゴロゴロ
はじめ）うわっ
たなっち）えー
はじめ）おーすごい
はじめ）ふたり？
男性）ひとり
はじめ）ひとり？えっ？　え？
たなっち）すげー今の…
はじめ）女の人の声したんですか？
男性）うん
はじめ）え、すご　たなっち）すげー
はじめ）もう1回聞かせてください
はじめ）おっお、マジかすげー　すげー
たなっち）すげーすげー
はじめ）可愛い
男性）よおおおおおおおおおおし
はじめ）いええええええええええぃ
はじめ）ごめんなさい
はじめ）こんばんは
女の子）こんばんは
はじめ）わぁ
はじめ）声が可愛いですね
はじめ）あのー失礼ですけどおいくつぐらいですか？
はじめ）若い！
はじめ）ちなみにYouTu、YouTube見る？
女の子）見ます
はじめ）おー見るんだ誰見るの？
女の子）はじめしゃちょーとか
はじめ）おおおおお　良いとこつくね〜　他に…
女の子）スポーツテニスとか
はじめ）なんて？
女の子）いやぁｗスカイピース
はじめ）あ、スカイピースね
はじめ）スィスェん
女の子）ｗｗ
女の子）ふふふｗｗｗ
はじめ）スェ　ｗｗｗｗ
たなっち）あああ
女の子）ふふ　　ﾄｩﾙﾙﾙﾝ
はじめ）もしもーし
男性）もしもーし
はじめ）こんばんは
男性）はい、こんばんは
はじめ）何歳ですかー？
男性）22
はじめ）22 あれ？じゃ同い年じゃん
たなっち）俺と同い年
はじめ）ともだ、後輩と同い年だよ
男性）あ、そうなんですか
はじめ）うん
男性）何されてるんですか？
はじめ）僕はYouTuberやってます
男性）あぁだと思いました
はじめ）えぇ？
はじめ）正解です
男性）ふふｗ
男性）ほんとすか？
はじめ）よくわかりましたね
男性）え、すごいえ？ほんとすか？
はじめ）ほんとっすほんとっす
男性）毎日見てますよ動画
はじめ）本当ですか？
男性）はい
はじめ）すいませんありがとうございます
はじめ）ちなみに1番好きなYouTuberは誰ですか？
男性）1番好きなYouTuberは、すいません
ﾄｩﾙﾙﾙﾝ
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】